今日はダンマパダの説明でございます
うーんと 七番目と八番目でしょうね
で すばーぬぱっしんびえらんたん
いんりえすあさんうたん
ぼーじぇなんひちゃまったんゆん
くしたんひーなびりあん
たんれぱさひーまーろ
わーとーるかんぶだんばらん
あすばーぬぱっしんびえらんたん
いんりえすすさんうたん
ぼーじぇなんひちゃまったんゆん
にっさっだんあらっだびりあん
たんれなっぱさひーまーろ
わーとーせーらんぶぱんぶらたん
という偈句です えーと
このだいたいこのダンマパダの偈に何か分かりませんだけど
まあ何かストーリーをつなげてるんですよ
エピソード で だからダンマパダ注釈書っていうのはかなり膨大になっています
で かなり大きいテキストに
何冊にも繋がる大きいテキストになっているのは
ダンマパダの偈の解釈
教えの解釈ではなくて
このエピソードにかなり場所を取られています
かなり大きな本になってます
ダンマパダの注釈書 で
今まで誰一人もこの疑うことなく
確実にこのエピソードに基づいて釈尊がこの偈を語ったんだよというふうには思ってはいるんです
で また ダンマパダの編集している方に言われたこともありまして
ダンマパダの私はエピソードは全部無視して教えだけ解説してきたんですね
それはいくらかもしかすると
読んではないと思いますけどね
耳に入ったと思います
で ダンマパダの大事なところはこのエピソードですよと
教えではないと ですから私はなんとかそこはもうちゃんとして
日本語でやりますよということで
テキストが色々できてますけどね
そこでそのエピソードなんか読んでみたら
私から見ればだらしないというか
大変仏教を分かってない人々に指導されて
結構やりにくいところはいくらかありますけど
で 私はこのエピソードっていうのはね
まあそんなに大事かっていうことは疑問に思ってるし
自分にとっては合ってないストーリーはものすごく出てくるし
あるいは同じ偈に 同じ偈ではなくて
いろんなところ出てくる教えがあって
同じエピソードをつなげているんですね
そうすると お釈迦様はある出来事について全部語ったならば
一箇所に入れてほしいしね
これも教えました これも教えました
これも教えましたと それもないしね
だからどう見ても適当にエピソードつなげたんではないかなとは思いますけど
では そういうわけで この教えは置いておいて
エピソードをやりましょうと思っているんです
で サーヴァッティという街ですね
そちらでこの ある兄弟が三人がいて
チューラカーラ マッジマカーラ
マハーカーラという名前の
で チューラっていうのは小ということで
マッジマっていうのは中ということで
マハーっていうのは大ということで
まあカーラっていうのは名前で
それで チューラカーラ
マッジマカーラ マハーカーラという兄弟三人
勝手につけた名前でしょうと思いますけどね
それでこの長男と三男は
いろんなところに行って品物を探してくる
商売に で 次男は全部店を開いて全部売ってるんです
それで三人が商売しているんです
で このまあ 長男と三男がいろんなところへ行くんだから
やっぱりもうサーワッティという町にも行ったことがあります
そこへ行って 人々は自分たちが 500台ぐらいのすごい大きな商売ですからね
言ったらだいたいいっぱい人々がね
何か何があるんでしょうかという買い物に来るんですけどね
あまりサーワッティの人々はそれほど興味はあるんじゃなくて
午後になってくると何かみんなあるところに行くんですね
それは何でしょうかと
自分より別な商売人が来ているんでしょうか
あるいは何でしょうかといて
自分たちも行ったところで
お釈迦様の説法を聞くために人々はみんな集まって集まるんだということがわかるんですね
で お釈迦様がその日はね
この誰が来たっても だいたい説法は理解する人に合わせちゃうんです
1000人いようか  1万人いようか
まあ心を込めて理解しようとしないならば
全くその人々のことは気にしない
ただ一人だけでも じっとこれを理解しますということで聞こうとしているんだったら
もう話は全部その一人な一人に合わせちゃうんです
他の人はもう全然気にしない
だから理解しなきゃ あんまりお釈迦様はそんなにも一生懸命相手にしようとはしないんです
この日はお釈迦様は この長男はね
なかなか何か物珍しく思ったかどうかわかりませんだけど
何か話を聞く気になってるんだよと
ということで その人に話を合わせてしまったんです
説法は そこでだいたい順番で初めて聞く人々だから
良いことって何ですか？悪いことって何ですか？なんで人間がこの世の中でいろいろ不幸になったりするんでしょうかとかね
幸福になるためにどうすればよろしいでしょうかとか
そういうふうにすごい単純なことを言うんですね
まず で そういうところですよ
お釈迦様は 政治的な考え方やら商売に関わるものやら
妻子生活に関わるものやら
もう家族はどういうふうにとか
いろんなことを語ってるんですね
で それはまあちょっとしたお遊びで言っているところで
そんなに大胆な知恵ということではありません
とにかく人間にとってはね
悪いことをしてはいけませんよと
すると何だかんだでもなくなってしまいますよと
ですから どんどんいいことをするべきですよと
いいことをして生活すると
この世も大変幸福で成功して幸せで生きていられると
幸せで生きていられると
心は大変楽しいんだから
満足感があるんだからね
死ぬ時も そういう人々はかなり満足感でよく頑張って生きてきましたと
何も悩むことは 後悔することはないんだぞと
しっかり人間として生きてきたんだということで死にますよと
死んだところで 必ずしもそういう人々は
寝ている人が目が覚めるような感じで天界に生まれますよと
それで天界で言ったら分からなくなりますから
お釈迦さんは全部明確に知ってるんだから
この天界というのはこういうこういうものでありますと
そちらのどれぐらい幸福喜びあるかと
それもまた説明する で
そこら辺も説明すると
もう誰でも天国に生まれたようなります
で 次にお釈迦様はもう天界だけじゃなくて
悪いことをする人々は苦しみのいろんな次元に生まれ変わりますよと
そこの場合は こういうこういう世界がありますよと
4つの地獄のことやら説明したりする
それからお釈迦様は次に
何ででしょうかとね 人が天国に行ったり地獄に落ちたりするのと
それがやっぱり人間の行為だよと
行いだよと というわけで
行いというものはどういうものかと
業の話に入るんですね
で 業の話に入ったところで
悪と善の説明をして それでやめ
やめなくてはいけない悪
悪いこと 罪 こういうこういうものだと
全部教えてあげる 大体まとめて10種類にしていますけど
かなりお話ししましたと思います
それで善行為もまとめて10種類にしていますけど
こういうことは善行為だよと
それまた善悪の話をする
それから業の話次に それよりも普通はできない
日常生活ではできない
妻子生活しながら いわゆる商売しながら
家族を守りながら  24時間いろんな普通に忙しいんだからね
今まで教える善徳っていうのは
特別な行為ではなくて
普通生きてる人々が生きている上で悪いことをやめてやっていることは
いい方向へ変えて変えて生活することなんですね
しかし ただ生きていただけではなくて
もうちょっと日常生活をちょっとストップして
ちょっと休憩を取って
月一回とかね 全ての仕事も家族のことも全部もう完全に休憩して
もうちょっと純粋に心を清らかにすることをするのは
それは誰 何よりも優れている善行為だよと
そこら辺で心は特別に育てる方法として
いろんな瞑想やらいろんなことを教える
瞑想なんかしたらどうなるのかというと
天国なんかに生まれませんよと
そういう人々は特別なところに生まれるんだよと
それは仏教用語で梵天と言いますけども
梵天のことを説明する
だから天国と比べると
それから天国の不自由なところ
今まで天国に生まれ変わったら
それほどすごいことないぞと思っていた人々に
天国っていうのはいろいろ問題ありますよと
この天界の不満なところ
不十分なところを説明して
それは何一つもないんだと
梵天に行ったら 梵天というのは心は変わらない
同じ心で何一つも苦しみがなく
すごい一貫して またあまりも想像できんほど長い時間そこでいるんだよと
天界に生まれたってのは
もう何万年ぐらい経つとまた死んだりする可能性もあるし
しかし梵天はそうじゃないんだよと
生まれたら寿命終わるまで確実に幸福でいられるんだと
その幸福の方が天界の幸福よりはもうはるかに優れているんだと
比べられないほど ということで
梵天に行く道っていうのを説明するんで
それはやっぱりただ日常生活しただけでは梵天には行きませんと
ちょっと休暇を取って
特別に心育てないといけないと
そこまで行ったところで
いくらか人間には何かストーリーをつなげて進んでいくんだからね
もうちょっとお釈迦様は題を変えるんですね
そういう風に生命っていうのは地獄に落ちたり
人間に戻ったり 天界に生まれたり
梵天に行ったりすると
どこに行っても寿命っていうものはあるんだよと
寿命が終わっちゃうと
そこで死ななくちゃいけないんだと
死んでまたどこかに生まれ変わりますから
その場合はまた業によって
行為によって生まれ変わったりするんだよと
そういうことで どこに生まれても終わりがないんだというところで
輪廻の話に持っていくんですね
輪廻ってどういうことかと
それで論理的に やっぱりこれは限りなく生命は生まれて死んで生まれて死んでいくんだよと
それで生まれて死ぬっていうのは場所がいろいろ変わるんですね
地獄か天国か人間か梵天がいろいろと
地獄もたくさんあります
人間の世界は一つだけですけど
人間の世界を見てもいろいろありますからね
生まれる場所によって
国によって 生まれた家族によってものすごく運命が変わったりするんだから
だから 単色ではないんです
人間の世界も で ブッダの立場から見ると
生命としてはものすごく統一している
たった一種の生命体ですけどね
多数ということはないんです
人間が一色で 能力も何から何まで同じだと
同じ工場で作った品物と同じようなものだと
あんまりお釈迦様は差があるとは思ってないんですね
とは思ってないんですけど
それはもう地獄やらね
例えば動物は一つの地獄なんですよ
動物の世界は では 一色ですかね
微生物からクジラまでいろいろあるでしょうに
それぞれ生命や寿命は違うでしょうに
生き方は違うでしょうに
生きる苦しみは大変さはそれぞれまた違うでしょうに
それがものすごい複数ですね
それで人間にしてみれば一色ですよと
輪廻の立場から人間はそうやって一色にしていますけど
私たちから見れば 人間はそうみんな同じというふうには見えませんね
そういうわけで 天界はものすごい難しい
梵天もものすごい難しい
ものすごい次元がある
たくさんあります 一番最高なレベルに優れたところだけ
梵天はみんな それもレベル４数いくつかありますけどね
一色になりますけどね
それじゃあ一色にならない
それで輪廻ということがある
死んだらまた生まれると
また死んだらまた生まれると
生まれたら死ぬんだよ
死んだら元で終わらなくまた生まれる
どうやって生まれるかというと
やっぱり行為の結果ですよと
それから輪廻のことを考えてくださいと
では天界に生まれて幸福ですか？と
長い間苦労しないで仕事をしないで生活できるんだから
嫌な人に会ったりとすることはないんだからね
その点では楽なんですね
では 遊んで楽しむことしか心清らかにする余裕はない
だから天界に一旦生まれたらそこでそこで死ぬでしょうに
だから天人たちが 私たちもやがて死ぬんだから
転生するんだから やっぱり来世のことを気をつけなくちゃいかんということは全く思い浮かびないんですね
だから天界は幸福か不幸かどうでしょうかと
それは普通の人間には
当時の人間には理解できるんですよ
なぜならば 幸福に厳密に恵まれている
王様たちやらね 貴族の人々やらね
召使いやらもう 100人 200人ぐらいいるわ
もう自分では何もやらなくてもよろしいわ
すごい贅沢三昧で生きている人々とかね
見ていられるんだから
いるんだからね やっぱりそういう人々は楽しむことで忙しいんですね
朝から晩まですごい忙しい
王様たち見たって もう朝早く起きて
夜遅くまでいろんなことをやらなくちゃいけない
一般の農民から見れば
もういつでも楽しくて贅沢三昧ではないかと
朝起きる時でもちゃんと色んなお世話やら色んな仕来りやりますから
王様の前で王様が目が覚めるまで
じーっとそのお世話係の人々はじーっともう制服を着て並んで並んでいるんだから
目が覚めたらまずこういう人はこういうことをするんだ
次にはこの人はこれやるんだとかね
やっぱり贅沢三昧ではないかと
王様の立場から見れば
朝から晩まで忙しいというかね
そういう仕来り儀式にずっと参加しなくちゃいけないんだ
だからいいことをしようという余裕がない
暇がないと 天国に生まれたらもっと状態がひどい
もっと楽しいんだからね
では 修行して瞑想して禅定すぎて梵天に行ったらどうかというと
梵天にいる間は禅定状態でずっと楽しんでいるんですけど
死を考える余裕が出てこないんですね
ある一貫したある一つの思考でサマーディ動態でいる
だから死ぬんだということは考えられないんです
そういう雑念なんか生まれてこない
雑念何もない 雑念も何もなく
すごくサマーディ状態でいるのはありがたい
もう増長する幸福なんですよ
しかし 死ぬ時は死にます
そこで何一つも準備できてないんですよ
先行しようか もっとさらに修行して
もっといいところに行こうかということも考える余裕がないんですね
だから梵天に至っても死んじゃうとちょっと心配だよと
心もエネルギーの状態から考えると
梵天で死ぬ人は地獄には落ちません
落ちられません もうかなり高いレベルの心だから
やっぱり次に死んじゃうと
あれよりはちょっと低いところに来ることは必ず来ます
一番最高な業で最高なレベルでいるんだから
その業が終わったら 1段階落ちるということは決まっているんです
それでそうやって輪廻のことを説明しますね
ということで どうでしょうかと
どこに生まれたらよろしいでしょうかと
人間というのは王様で生まれたらよろしいですか
天国に生まれ変わったらよろしいでしょうか
梵天に生まれ変わったらよろしいでしょうかと
やっぱり素晴らしいところだよと言って
まあどこやっぱり言っても
なんかちょっと我に合わないんではないかと
こちらで一生懸命瞑想して禅定作って梵天に生まれる
そこで何光年もそちらで幸福でサマーディ状態でいられる
寿命終わったらどうしますか？と
落ちなくてはいけないんですよ
だからそれを考えると
なんかちょっと不安になるはずなんです
それで そういう人々はそうやって
この次の輪廻の話になってくると不安になってくるんですね
どうしようかと いいことをして立派な在家生活をしようかなと思っても
せいぜい天国に行くだけであって
そこからまた善行する余裕がなくなっちゃうんだから
地獄に落ちるかもしれませんし
地獄に落ちちゃったらどうしようかと
ではそれだったら瞑想するぞと思ってプブンテに生まれたっても
また落ちるんだから ということで
全体的に輪廻に対するこの不安をじりじりと感じさせる
で 不安をじりじりと感じさせると
やっぱりどんなものでもそんなもんで一時的で変化するんだよと
だからそれが私のもの
これが私の人生だと思った時点で間違ってるんだよと
それは無知だよ 無知ではいい結果が出てこないんだよ
そういうわけで この全て捨てた方がいいんだよ
輪廻を脱出した方がいいんだよ
輪廻をしない方がいいんだよ
心にあるすべてのこの生きていきたいという欲望と無知をね
捨てた方がいいんだよと
それを捨てるためにどう考えればよろしいかと
それは一切は苦でありますと
なぜ苦かというと不安だから
不安なのに なんでそんなにしがみついてるかというと
あなた方の心にえらく渇愛が欲があるんだよと
いくら食べても満足しない
いくら遊んでも満足しない
もっとやりたいという
だからどんなひどい目に遭っても
しかしやるぞで立ち上がっちゃいますよと
やるぞと言ったっても
ずっと同じパターンだよと
ということで 四聖諦を説明して
心清らかにするヴィパッサナーというかね
智慧の観察法を最後に教えると
それお釈迦様の説法の順番なんです
在家の人 だから話を聞いた人が乗っていたならば
説法終わるともう大体夜中ぐらいには悟るんです
だから 1万人が集めたところで一人だけ乗っているんだったら
その人に説法します あの9999人は全然いるとも思わないんです
全く役に立たないんだからね
その人々は だからなんですよ
お釈迦様の話を聞いて
みんな悟り開いたっていうことはね
お釈迦様にの狙いというか
お釈迦様がやっぱりもう顔を合わせた
目を合わせたっていうことは大変ありがたいことで
自分には自分の心にちょっと合わせてくれたっていうことはね
だから大勢の人々はかなり真面目に聞く
そういう話をこのマハーカーラさんが
長男がね 真剣に聞いたんです
聞いたと 自分がもうで白台の車でいろんな品物を持ってきて
このもうインドでもかなり大きい繁栄しているこのサワッティという町に来てね
商売しようかなと思ったら
なんかものすごく嫌な気持ちになっちゃったんですよ
何やってるんですかと
これぐらいゴミを集めてみんなに売りさばいて
またこちらから品物を買って
自分の村 町に帰って そちらでまた次男に任せて次男にも商売させてとかね
結局は死ぬ時はただ何一つも持たないで死ぬでしょうと
なんてつまらないことをやってるんですかと
ものすごくもう自分がやっていることを
自分の生き方に対してすっごく嫌になってなっちゃったんです
それでもう もうこんなことはもうやりたくないという気持ちになりましたからね
もうもうだからもう それはお釈迦様の順番の説法を聞かないと
その気持ちはわからないと思いますけどね
梵天まで話して 人を喜ばせて
素晴らしいところあるんだぞと
次に業と輪廻の話になるんだからね
それから全部まとめて空中滅道の話に持っていくんだからね
何についてももう未練がなくなっちゃうんですね
で 彼が出家したいということで
お釈迦様に出家お願いしますというところで
あんたに誰か責任者がいるんですかと
断る人がいるんですかと言ったら
まあまあ強いて言えば弟がいるんだよと
一緒に来たんだからね
まあ一応彼に断りなさいと言ったら
弟にね 君は商売しなさいよと
だから弟は話聞いてないんですよ
二人で一緒に行ったかもしれませんですけど
全部君でやりなさいと
君一人で 私には何一つも要りませんと
このまま出家するんだと
全財産彼にあげちゃいますけどね
それでもうとにかくこの長男がかなりやり手やと思いますけど
長男が出家する もう三男がすっごく反対するんですよ
兄貴がないとどうしますかと
私はできませんとかなんとかとかね
もうもう商売できるわけないんではないかとかね
言ってももう聞かない
一人でやりなさいと で
出家する それからもしかすると商売やらあまりうまくいかなかったでしょうね
これはもうダメやと言って
この三男は私も出家するんだと
出家してまた長男をね
兄貴をね なんとか話し合って
戻すとか 戻ってもらいましょうと家に
なんとか話し合って もう家がもう商売うまくいかないし
バラバラでしょうし ですから
これはもうたまらないと
兄貴がないと全部ダメやということで
帰ってもらいたく 本人も三男も出家する
で 長男が一応それで出家して真面目に修行する
[紙をめくる音]そこで長老にこの
この何かいいことが起きたみたいですね
あるもの ものすごい綺麗な女の人が
ものすごい若い若い娘さんが突然病気になって死んでしまったんです
死んでしまったところで
まあ親戚はまだまだ結婚
お嫁に行ってない美しい娘さんですからね
かなり派手に遺体をね
まあいろいろ着飾らせて
あの まあ葬式をしようと
で 葬式は一応火葬する場合は
インドでカースト制度がありますから
まあ遺体カーストも燃やすカーストは別々にいる
で その人々のところにまあ持っていって渡したんです
これはお願いしますと
まあそちらの責任者は女の人で
その女の人があまりにも綺麗な娘がね
ということでね で まあ服はお坊さんたちやらみんな持っていきますからね
そちらにあげたりする
遺体にまとって捨てる服
ほとんどお坊さんたちが使っていたんですからね
そこで まあこれはお坊さんたちには役に立ちますよと
衣作るためにということで
服を全部親戚が言っちゃったらね
もうやりたい放題だから
遺体に対しては で まあこれはどこでも同じことでね
日本にいたって葬儀屋さんはやりたい放題ですけど
それはもう死なれた方々はまあ仏様やとか泣き崩れたりと
とんでもないことをやっちゃってもね
葬儀屋さんにしてみれば何のこともないんです
蹴ったりなんでも まあお化けが怖いんだからどうか分かりませんだけど
で 彼女は服は全部取ったんですよ
取ったらこの娘の体を見たら
もうなんて綺麗な体ですかと言って
さっさとこの長男のお坊さんにね
言ってお坊さんが見てもらいたいものがありますよと
でお坊さんも連れて行ったんですね
この綺麗な女の人の死体をね
これ見てくださいと 見たら
もうあまりにも綺麗なもう体をね
で 服も何もない 見ると
男の人の心にいろいろ欲が生まれてくる
それでそのお坊さんが見ている間で
彼女はこれを燃やすんですよ
遺体を まず綺麗な体を見せてね
座って見ていてくださいと
それからもう薪の捨ててもう燃やすんですよ
インドの火葬の仕方っていうのは
この薪の上に遺体を入れて燃やすんですよ
そうすると全部見えるんですね
今はもう見せませんですけど
一応やり方とやり方 で
このお坊さんがあの綺麗な体の女の子がもう焼かれて燃えてる音をじっと見て
瞬間でえらい醜くなったんではないかと
火がつけた瞬間に醜くなっちゃうんですね
見るものすごい速いんです
で 人間の体っていうのはかなり燃えますね
面白いことに で もう脂いっぱいたまってるんだ
で 皮膚なんかはもう下全部脂ありますからね
すぐ燃えます 燃えるともういろんな袋みたいなね
もう泡みたいなもの出てきて
あっちこっちからパコパコと弾けて
それだけで体があの銀金色色の体ではなくなっちゃうんです
まあそれだけ見てね ものすごくショックを受けて
まあこれが人生やということでね
で 寺に戻って瞑想して悟り開くんです
で 次男も次男はそんなことは何もなし
まあとにかく考えているのは
まあ兄貴がもう出家もつまらないなと何か不満出てくるまでもう待ってるんですね
その時は家に帰りましょうと
帰ってまた商売始めましょうと言いたくて言いたくているだけで
長男がやっぱり出家した目的達して阿羅漢になっていて
阿羅漢になったところで
二人ともまた戻ってお釈迦様に礼をしましょうということを寺に来る
で そしたらこの家の奥さんたちがやっぱり二人戻ってきたんだと
ということは知ったんですね
この頃チャンスなんですね
やっぱり還俗してもらうために
だからみんな家族ぐるみで計算して計画を立てて
還俗させようとしているんだからね
まあ三男も出家したんだけど
三男も三男でなかなか早く兄貴連れて帰ってこないしね
だからどうなってるかと
結局また斎場に戻ったところで
まあもうなんとかチャンスだよということで
で この家の三男の人 家はもうお釈迦様とお坊さんたちにお布施しますということでお布施をする約束をする
それからこの前の日ではなくて
前の日 この家に この何て言いますかね
あれはお釈迦様とかお坊さんたちが来るんだから
この座席の順番やらね
もう座るところのどういう風に来ますかとかね
式台はどうしますかということを教えてあげなくちゃいけない
それを教えるために 親戚だから
自分の家だから 君が行って全部用意しなさいと
お坊さんたちがこの三男のお坊さんに言ったんですね
言ったら自分の家だからね
遠慮なく何でも言えるし
家に行ったらこの女たちがね
まあこの人を誘惑して何するんですかとね
こんな変な頭剃って何だこの格好悪いとかね
こんなもう楽しく生活できるのにね
バカなことをやるもんだなとかね
言っていろんなことをして
もうもう誘惑しちゃったんですね
で 彼が出家を置いておいて
女たちと自分の奥さんたちなんですけどね
よく遊んで で もうで なんとかそれなりにお釈迦様とお坊さんたちのために座るところはそれなりに用意して
夜は寺に戻らないんですね
とにかく家にも仕事 で
朝時間になってくると
自分がもう普通の在家の服を着て
もう頭を髪の毛がないんだから
そちらに何かもう帽子みたいなものをつけてお寺に行くんですね
言って食事の用意ができましたということで
お坊さんたちが見たら
もうなんてみっともない姿ですかと
真面目な比丘でいて もう家に行ったところで
もう帰ってくるともう寺に帰ってくると
ただの在家の馬鹿もんなんですね
すごくショックというか悲しいというかね
なんて惨めな人間かと
で とにかくそれで食事が終わって
で それを聞いたら この長男の奥さんたちもやっぱり三男が簡単に戻ってもらったんだと
あの女たちが 我々も頑張らなきゃあかんと
私たち頑張ったらその人は家に帰ってくるでしょうということで
自分たちもまたお釈迦様に食事の用意をする
で お釈迦様はいいというだけで終わりますから
この他の準備はお坊さんたちの責任だからね
でお坊さんたちが考えたんです
この家にまた誰が送るべきかともう大変なことになったんだからね
だから たとえ自分の家だからといっても
このマハーカアラお坊さんを長老を送るわけにはいきませんと
何されるかわからないんだと言って
全くの関係ないお坊さんをあんた行って準備用意してくんなさいと言われたんです
だから女たちが待っているんだけど
知らないお坊さんが来るんだから
これは失礼なことをするわけにはいきませんし
そのお坊さんの言われた通りに全部用意して
お坊さんが寺に戻る で
次の朝は家の人々が家来がいて報告する
お坊さん お釈迦様と比丘たちがもうそちらに行く
このマハーカアラ長老が行く
もう女たちになかなか時間場がないんですね
自分の旦那を誘惑する場がないんですね
で 失敗しましたからね
午後来ると思ったところはできな来なかったんだから
それで考えたのは 食事が終わったらお釈迦様説法しますからね
食事終わった途端 お釈迦様が手を洗ったところで
お釈迦様に実はこのマハーカアラ長老から説法を聞きたいんだと
修行に行ったんだから
その人の修行 いわゆる成功を見たいという感じでね
彼から説法を聞きたいんですから
いかがでしょうかと 言ったら
お釈迦様がいいですよと言って
比丘たちにじゃあ帰りましょうと言って
みんなそれでお釈迦様帰るんです
私がいると もしかするとこのマハーカアラに説法できないかもしれませんし
年上の長老たちがいると
これちょっともう面倒くさいしね
だからみんな帰りましょうと
マハーカアラにあんた適当に説法して帰りなさいということで言って
もうお釈迦様は寺に帰るんですね
それでお坊さんたちがなんか不安で
どういうことでこれ来ないんではないかと
このマハーカアラ長老をなんとか守ろうと
お坊さんたちはいろいろ頑張ったのに
それ見たらお釈迦様はもうとんでもないことをするんです
説法しなさいと待っていればいいのに
あるいは他のお坊さんに君たち待ちなさいと
見張りなさいと言ったら
お坊さんたちはすごい喜んで見張っておくんですよ
で みんな連れて帰っちゃったんです
それで女たちは全然説法する気はまるっきりなく
で あれやこれやとかね
体は見せたり いろんなことをしたり
誘惑しようと もうからかったりしてね
もうなんだこんな汚い服を着たりとかね
こんなに贅沢あるのにね
もうどうしようもないね
これとかね いろいろ言ったり
で マハーカアラ長老がね
もう悟ってるんで だからね
そんな言うわけに 負けるわけにはないしね
まあどないせよ 「お前らはね
何考えてるんですか」と 「
それってもうもうそんなに面白いと思ってるんですか」と
言って まあ結局説法してね
帰るんです それでお坊さんたちがね
もう心配で心配でたまらなかったんですけど
何のことなくマハーカアラ長老がもう説法して打ち捨ててお寺に帰る
それ見てお坊さんたちはびっくりしてね
必ずしもこれがもう知っていたんだからね
このお布施も本当のお布施じゃなくて
これはからくりでしたと知っていたし
マハーカアラ長老を泊まってもらったのも
そのお坊さんを誘惑するためであるということも知っていましたし
家ぐるみでみんなこの一人のお坊さん捕まったりしまうとどうにもならんだからね
でも うまく見事に帰ってきたんだわな
あの方ね それはまあ お釈迦様にそれ言われたところで 「
あんた方はね マハーカアラのことそんなにも心配していたんですか」と 「
私は全然心配しないよ」と
ということで まあそれがストーリーです
それでどういう差がありますかと
チューラカーラとマハーカーラの間ではね
というところで お釈迦様は一応真理を語るんですね
で ストーリーを言うと
なかなかこの偈の説明はできないんです
というわけで もう時間ぐらいの時間も経ちましたし
日本の席だれによってストーリーが大事ですからね
欲が増える話しか聞かないんですからね
とにかく合わないんですよ
この偈の内容とストーリーはね
まあ意味はまあ一応そこら辺どこかどこかで書いてるでしょうね
それなりに subhānupassī
viharanta indriyēsu asaṃvutaṃ bhōjanaṃ hi ca amattaññu kusītaṃ hīna vīriyaṃ
taṃ vā pasati māro vātō rukkhaṃ va dubbalaṃ subhānupassī
っていうのはもう見方
まあ物事 これsubaとasubaっていうのは
まあそう簡単に訳できないんです
これ専門的な言葉なんです
仏教の subaはもうただ綺麗
素晴らしい 良いという意味なんです
しかし サンスクリット語
パーリ語ではそれだけでは終わらないんですよ suba
といえば幸福という意味もあります asuba
といえば不幸という意味もあります asuba
は反対の言葉 a入れちゃえばasubaなんです
反対の意味です で それから仏教でasubaといえば不浄という意味でも使います
しかし 不浄って言ったら何かちょっとそんなに意味があるとは思いませんですけどね
わからない私はね とにかく
まあそう簡単にはね 訳できんとは思いますよ
だから専門用語なんです
英訳ありますかね？そちらに
はい はい 英訳もされてないんですね
では あのー どうしよう
とにかくsubhānupassī
私は一応私が考えている意味を言います
皆様はもう納得いくならばそれはありがたいし
別にありがたくもないんですけど
あの 認めないならばテキストにある意味でよろしいんです subhānupassī
っていうのは 例えば私の場合
私は自分の人生 世の中
どのように見ているかという見方のことなんです
だからこれ人しかないんですよ
私が自分のことと 世間
世間のこと 世の世のこと
どのように見ているかと
自分の見方なんですよ
それで そのその人に自分の見方っていうものはありますよ
どんな生命であろうとも見方があるんですよ
生きるということは 情報を心に入れることには生きることなんです
それはちょっと理解してほしい
もう強引な仏教の解釈だから
生きているということは
仏教は見ているのは単純で見ているんですね
生命はありがたいとかね
尊いとか もうというふうな
この なんか把握しにくい
我々にとってはわからない意味なんですね
しかし 俗世間ではすごくわかるんですが
仏教から見れば 生きているということは
目で見るは耳で聞くは頭で考えるは舌で味わうは
そういう刺激過程が生きていることだと
それストップしたら死んでるんだよと
目で見えない 耳で聞こえない
鼻で嗅げない 舌で味わえない
体で何も感じない 頭でもゴチャゴチャと妄想することはもう止まったと
止まったらもう死んでるんですね
だから生きてるということは
あらゆる六根ですから
六根から刺激を受けて心を回転させてるだけなんですね
それでこの情報に対してどんな受け取り方をしているかということは当たり前ありますよ
そのその人に それが人ではなくて
生命に対して すべて生命にあることな生命が生命ですよ
生きているものやと言えば
幽霊でもお化けでも何でもいいんですよ
生き物であるならば 生きているということは
仏教の定義では情報を受け取っていることなんですね
この物体が 物体はお化けでも何でもいいんです
何か外の情報を受け取ったり
その場合は体も外と言いますけど
体その体からの情報でもね
あるいは心そのもの中からの
でも妄想っていうのは心の中から出てくる刺激なんですね
だから心の中から刺激が現れて
それを認識して妄想し続けるんですね
この唯識仏教はそれだけ取ってるんですけど
元々初めの仏教は別にそれ一部だけですね
大乗仏教やら部派仏教というのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃった一つの教えだけとって
ものすごい大きいシステムを作る
他の教えはもうなかったことにするというやり方ですからね
部派に分かれた時は だから唯識論に至っても
ある心の一つの働きを見て
それが絶対的にしてしまって
それだから邪見になるんです
ブッダの教えでなくなっちゃうんです
本当はブッダの教えの一部なんですけど
結局システム化してたところでブッダの教えでなくなっちゃうんです
だから唯識論でいうのは
この外の世界は存在しない
すべて自分の心が投影したものであると
投影論言うんですね だから阿頼耶識という
なんとかわかる 見たことはないんですけど
あって その阿頼耶識からマナ識というものが出てきて
それから六識が出てきて
六識っていうのは外の世界は作る機能なんですね
そこで外の世界あるんだよと自分が錯覚しているだけですと
あるわけじゃないというふうに
全くブッダがしようとしないことをしようとしているんですね
いわゆる形而上学を語ろうとするんですね
だからそういうのは まあまあ
西洋哲学の言葉で言えば
やっぱりメタフィジックスという方に入るものなんですね
で ブッダはメタフィジックスは絶対もう何の役にも立たんだから語ってないんですね
だから心理学のように聞こえますが
この有識はね 本当はそうかなとね
心理学じゃないんですけどもね
まあとにかく仏教から見れば
初期仏教から見れば もう目から耳からいろいろ情報が入る
それは外から入る 体でも
ああ 足が痛い 腰が痛いと思っちゃうと
体も物体だから外のものとして見る
痛い時は痛い 嫌やと思うのは普通なことだから
そこで体に何か故障があって
その故障が引っかかって
心がその情報を受けたら刺激して痛い
嫌やという感じがする
そういうもの何もなくても
頭自分勝手に過去のことやら
あることもないことも思い出しては妄想する
だから一番ややこしいというか
このもうもう危険というかね
心はなぜ輪廻して なぜ輪廻するか
なぜ心が止まらないかということは
心にはいつも刺激があるんだからなんです
心には刺激ない瞬間っていうのは一つもない
何もなければ思い存分妄想する
だから心という定義も刺激に反応するって意味なんです
だから寝ていたとしても心があるでしょう
寝たっても刺激があるんですよ
そこで即世間に陥っている人々は
もうあまり刺激がない
つまらないんだ 退屈やと思ってる
あれは勘違いで ただあまりにも鈍感だから
ド派手な音やらド派手な美しいものやら
ド派手な美味しいものやら
なければつまらなくなるだけで
あれは無知ということなんですよ
刺激はいつもあるんですよ
だから退屈は退屈だということもすごい刺激なんですよ
寝ても刺激があるということだから
生きているということはそういうことなんです
それでどんな生命でも
ミミズでも幽霊でもライオンでも誰でも
生き物だから刺激は受けている
それでそのその生命が
この外の刺激 内の刺激に対してどのように受けているかということは当たり前あるんです
受け取らなきゃもう全く話にならないんだから
死んでいるか悟っているかどちらかなんです
刺激は受け取れないというのは
悟っていたっても もう悟りのお釈迦様の悟りの禅定に入ってないと刺激受けているんです
それもそう簡単に入ることできるものじゃないんですよ
いわゆる心の心そのものをストップさせて刺激ストップさせるんではなくて
刺激を受けないということは心のストップなんです
これが瞑想のサマーディの中で一番難しいこと
悟ることはそんなに難しい
比べてみると難しいとは言えないんですが
この悟りの禅定に入って心をストップ機能にするということは
もうものすごい難しい
修行してヴィパッサナーして悟りの心を作ることはできます
一旦作ったら煩悩が消えちゃう
それでまあただ普通に生きているだけで
煩悩がなくなっちゃうと
もう心は汚れませんし
大丈夫です まあとにかく
だから刺激がないと言うとおかしいんです
刺激は刺激を受けているんです
受けているんだから 生命に心があるということと全く同じなんですよ
情報を見る見方もあるっていうことは
誰かが いえ 私は全然そういう先入観やら見方やら
そんなのは全然持ってないんだぞと言ったら
それが見方なんです いわゆる曖昧で中途半端で
何 何についても真剣でない性格ということなんです
偉そうなこと言っても
私はあまり気にしませんよとかね
私に向き いろんな人々がね
私なんかはそういうことにはあまり興味ないから
あまり気にしませんよとかね
気持ち悪いだけなんですよ
もっと興味があって もうバカみたくしがみついてやってる人の方が可愛いんですけどね
何かやる時はバカみたくそこに入り込んじゃってやって
人のアプローチがはっきりしているし
悠々不断ということもないし
で 育てようと思ったらすぐ育てられますよね
だからどんな餌に来るかとわかったら
その餌を撒ければ撒けばいいんだからね
何にも興味ないという人が別に
どんもうどうにもならんだけのこと
とにかく もし人が私は別にそんなにお祭りあると言ったって別に興味がないとかね
音楽に別に興味がないとかね
私はすごく別に興味がない
そんな先入観も何もないと言ったっても
それはその人の見方であって
他の激しく活動する人々と比べると
なんかもう気持ち悪いというかね
何にも何もやられない人間というかね
役に立たないような もうまあという
それがその人のアプローチであって
とにかく一切の生命には情報に対するアプローチというものがあります
それは避けられない それで
そのアプローチをブッダがお釈迦様がスバとアスバと二種類に分けています
お釈迦様何でもほとんどのものを二つに二つに分けます
その方が理解しやすいんですよ
一切の情報についてスバという
だからスバっていうのは良いもの
幸福なもの 価値あるもの
意味のあるもの 大事なものというアプローチなんです
アスバといえばそちらの反対なんです
だから訳できません 通訳は
では二つに分けても 我々はどんなアプローチでいますかと
ブッダの話を聞いてない限りは聞いただけでダメですよ
聞いて納得して理解していない限りはね
それだけでもダメです
その見方 見方で生きてみるぞと努力しない人限りはね
すべての生命にあるのはスバというアプローチなんです
誰を 誰を見ても みんなスバというアプローチで
良いもの 価値あるもの
意味のあるもの 何か意味があるものやというアプローチで見ています
[笑い]例えば何かわけもわからない音が耳
音が耳に入ったとしてください
そうすると心はどうなりますか
引っかかっちゃう  えっ？ 引っかかっちゃいます
何だろうと  あの音なんだろうと
なんでそういうふうに起こるんですかね
どんな音かと頭は理解しなかったんですよ
しかし先入観で意味があるはずなんです
スバなんで先入観は だから何だろうと
あの音は 入ったところで何だろうとわからなかったんですよ
これがあかんと スバで見ているんだから
音に何か意味があるはずですよと
何か価値があるはずですよと
ということで 何だろうという気持ちが出てくるのです
だから すべての生命が持っているアプローチはスバというアプローチなんです
だからなんですよ この真理はブッダ以外誰にも発見できないのは
そこそこの研究者に もうそこそこの修行者に
そこそこではなくて 一生をかけて年
五年も森に入ってきて
入り込んじゃって瞑想をいろいろしたっても
この真理は発見できないんですよ
なぜならば 例えばすべての生命がスバというアプローチでいるならば
どうやって発見できますかね
いわゆる区別できますかね
他のもの見つからないでしょうに
だから研究する人々は他のものを探しているんですよ
じゃあ 生命の場合は まあこれは当たり前で
その中で何か区別あるんでしょうかと
だからこれ大変 です だから
まあ地球上に生きている生命はみんな呼吸しているんだよというような感じで
それがもう当たり前で
それ以上は何も考える必要なくなっちゃうんですよ
それから考えるのは呼吸の取り方だけなんですよ
エラで取るか肺で取るか
皮膚で取るかっていうぐらいなもんなんですよ
呼吸をする生命と呼吸しない生命っていう区別は成り立ちませんでしょ
分別は 例えば誰かが生物学者がいるとしましょう
その生物学者は地球にあるすべての生命のことを分析しようとする
その時は その人が分析するのは
例えば呼吸の題に入っても
呼吸の取り方であって
酸素はどのように取るかと
そうすると皮膚から酸素を取る生命がいるんだそうと
肺から取る人 生命がいるんだそうと
皮膚からも肺からも両方取る生命もいるんだそうと
いろいろ あるいは酸素はお腹の中にどこかで溜まっておいて
体の中にゆっくりと取ったりする生命体もいるんだぞとかね
という分析になるんです
それで呼吸する生命と呼吸しない生命っていうのを分析しちゃうと
あんたバカではないかということになるんですよ
どこにもいないんだから
そういう生命は 科学者ではありませんと
あんた ということになるんです
だから 生命のアプローチはスバであるということは
すべての生命はスバというアプローチでいるんだから
スバというアプローチの生命
見方 ありますよということは
お釈迦様と悟った人以外
お釈迦様ではなくて 以外は発見できないものなんです
私が言うことは嘘だと思うならば
世界にあるすべての宗教を調べてみてください
みんなスバというアプローチを
で書いてかかって語っているんです
生命はダメや 人間は世界はダメやという人も出ますよ
でもその人は別な価値を
別な生命がある 別な次元があるということを言ってるんです
そちらは楽しいよと だからこの芸っていうのは
まあ普通はまあどんな苦労さんでも簡単に説明して終わっちゃいますけど
ブッダの教えというのはそう簡単なものでもないんです
では どんな用語で翻訳すればよろしいんですかね
スバっていうのは やっぱり見るものに何か価値がある
何か意味がある 何かがあるという感じなんですよ
何かがあるという感じになっちゃうと
そのものにピッタリと執着してしまっちゃうんです
避けられない だからスバという見方で生きてると
もう輪廻にぴったしとついていて
輪廻転生するんですよ
もう嫌と 嫌と思ってもできないんで
嫌と思っただけではこの機能が治らない限りはもうしょうがないんです
そこで あの執着と言った途端
またちょっと即次元です
あの 間違うところあります
例えば音が入ったというところ
もしその音が気に入る音だったら
もういい音だよってもはっきり判断していますよ
しかし 分からなかったんだから
あの綺麗な音なんだろうという風に調べるんです
そこで このスバのスバというアプローチで見ると
見たものは綺麗なものか
醜いものかと判断する
それは欲と怒りなんですが
それより裏にあるのはスバというアプローチなんですよ
例えば こちらには価値がある
この価値が私が嫌です
あなたはものすごい不細工で醜い
だから見たくないと もう価値ですよ
価値 価値というのは価値入れてるんですよ
それからあなたのこと大嫌いやとか
腹が立ちますよとか どんどん怒りが湧いてくると
価値を入れたな 入れてなかったならば
その怒りが湧いてこない
逆に あんたってすごい美しいんではないかと
気に入ったと 仲良くしましょうと欲が出てくる
だから怒りも欲もスバから出てくるんです
そういうわけで これがもう仏教の世界でも解説してないポイントなんです
先生  はい  サティをしてる時っていうのはアスバ？ ん？ サティをしてる
サティを入れてる時っていうのはアスバ？ うん
だからそれの真似事ですよ
うん  で スバの状態でサティしてても全然それもうダメということですか？ダメというか
まあもうかなり苦しんですよ
例えば あの 呼吸する時に吸います吐きますっていう感じですね
で それからプラティになります
で 吸います吐きますっていうのはスバ？
そういう風には言いませんですけどね
手を上げます 下ろしますっていうのはね
まあそれはスバではない
入ったり入らなかったりします
秘密ではない？ いえ 例えばもうちょっと
例えばまあ背伸びをしてちょっと機嫌よくしようかなと思っちゃうと手を上げますでしょ
手を上げます スバなんです
で 私はヴィパッサナーでやると手を上げてみなさい
上げます 下げますと それ何の目的もないでしょ
その場合は で その時はもう正しい見方なの
正しいじゃなくて 仏教言ってる見方なんです
はい 微妙です うん まあ例えば私はこうやって手を置いておいて
もうちょっともう血跡の流れやらね
神経の響きはなんかちょっと鈍くなってくると機嫌が悪いと気持ちが悪いし
それで私はサティ入れながら手を伸ばします
伸ばします 伸ばし じっと手を伸ばしていい気持ちになる
で こう言えばちゃんとヴィパッサナーでやったかもしれませんだけど
なんかどこかですばなんですよ
意味があるんだからね
こういうに期待があるんだから
結果を望んでいるんだから
そこら辺は微妙 しかし
ただ実況してやればもううまくいきますからね
で うまくいかないで なんか修行が嫌になったり
苦しくなったりすると
やっぱりその微妙にこのすばの状態をまだまだ報復
報復っていうんですか
乗り越えてないっていうかね
難しいんですよ ものすごい難しい
説明難しいんだから 注釈書にさえも説明してないんです
注釈書で実践の世界で
我々はそんな頭がいいわけじゃないんだから
我々は昔の人々もみんな同じですよ
だからたまのまに我々にはどうすればいいかっていうところではもうめちゃくちゃ説明あるんです
でも この本当の微妙な心理のところはもう触ろうとしない
私も口で喋るんであって
書こうとしちゃうとできないと思います
いいですか あの あすばの
あすばっていうのはある意味では死んでるっていうか
生きてることと違う 違いますよね
いや すばの反対 すばっていう意味の反対です
それだけ  それじゃああの生きてるっていう
あの 仏教の定義だと 何かを感じてるっていうか
情報に反応してるっていう意味ですね
そしてそうじゃないっていうことは
死んでるってことですよね
はい  そうすると あの 例えば瞑想をするというのは
死んでる状態にを目指そうとしてるという方向と考えていいんですか？ 全くダメです
全くダメ 要するに反応しないわけですよね
反応するのは生きてるんだからなんですよ
たとえ瞑想したっても
それ自体反応だから この反応はすば反応はダメですよって言ってるだけで
あすば反応しなさいと
だからあすば反応っていうのがあるんですか？ あるんだからね
あすば反応を瞑想はあすば反応をこうできる訓練みたいな
あすば反応の我々はちょっともぎ
何て言いますか あれはちょっとした真似事というかね
誰かが立派な言葉を使ってあったんですけどね
疑似体験  疑似体験みたいなもんなんですよ
だからなんか余地ないでしょう
何でも実況でやっちゃうと
実際にそういうふうにできるように近づくための方向っていうか
この疑似体験でもうどんどんどんどんなりますから
あの間違ってるのは これはあの仮死状態を真似事してるわけじゃない
これは生と死と関係ないんです
生きてるのは当たり前で
前提であって 生きてることの定義は刺激に反応することであって
こちらの問題はすば反応するなかれということなんです
こちらの教えは  それでは
あの 受想行識の受で止めるということでのしましょう
意味を受け取らないってことですね
え あの まあ五蘊のことを言ってるでしょ
で 五蘊のことをこの場合はあんまり当てはめないんですが
まあ言えば受で止まるっていうことでは理解しても悪くはないんですけど
五蘊は別な解釈に使うんですよ
いわゆる五蘊で生きてるんだとするならば
受で止まれっていうこと
そういう解釈だったらいいんです
なんか単純に答えられないんだから
本当にもう申し訳ないんですけど
やっぱり心理っていうのはね
ただ言葉の遊びじゃないんですよ
だから 言葉を使った人がどんな意味で取ってるかっていうことを私は知らないと答えられないんですね
だから 今私は強引に自分の定義を強引に押し付けただけ
だから 五蘊っていうのは生命イコール五蘊というならば
だったらその中の受で止まってくださいということで
それでこの  死ぬことの
あの 何でしたっけ？ 疑似体験
疑似体験とか そんなのとんでもない話で
それだったら麻酔剤かけてもらったら簡単便利で楽でしょうしね
誰かに頭に思い存分殴ってくださいと頼んじゃうとね
瞬時に済むもんですから
まあそういうのではではありません
いわゆる刷で見ることをやめてみなさいと
それで刷で見るということが
もう説明しましたね 意味がある
価値がある だから執着が現れる
それで見事に無常が関わるんですよ
意味があると思ったところで
矛盾を否定しているんです
例えばシャボン玉は明らかに綺麗ですよ
でも誰も価値があると思ってますかね
あ こんな綺麗なものを大事にしなくちゃと思う人はいますかね
私はいないと思いますけど
いるならば言ってください
シャボン玉っていうのはかなり綺麗なもの
それを誰でも知っていると思います
綺麗なものだったら普通は大事にするんじゃないの？普通は
あ これがすごい綺麗な絵
これはすごい綺麗な人
これはすごい綺麗な花
これは綺麗な植物だよとわかったらどうしますか？動物でなんて綺麗な動物ですか
例えばパンダとかなんて綺麗可愛いですかと思っちゃうと
どれぐらい大事にしてるんですかね
パンダにかかるお金で人間だったら何人育てられますかね
あの そもそも刷というのは
あの まず基本的に想念であって
しかもそこでの価値判断
裁きといいますか 常に価値判断だから
いい悪いとか上だ下だとか
そうするとあの 我々の日常生活っていうのは
朝起きてから寝るまで
その頭 想念っていうのはいつも価値判断っていう刷をしてるんですね
そうすると いわゆるあの
その刷をしないということが
我々の日常生活 普通の精神状態ではものすごい困難
ほとんどそのやってない行為なんですね
全くやってない行為 だからお釈迦様のすごいところは
それをできるようにしてあげるんですよ
日常生活の中でも  つまらないことですけれども
キリスト教では裁く流れというのはあるらしいんですけども
同じような  同じじゃないんですよ
それは人を裁く流れだからね
裁くことは神の仕事をやる
なんて裁くことはとんでもない罪ですよ
なぜならそれは神の仕事だから
神にしかできんことを人間どもがやろうと思っちゃうと
これ自体は神を侮辱したことで
神を否定したことなんでもう重罪になるんですね
そういう意味で裁く流れと言ってるんです
こんな虫こわくに基づいて言ってるわけじゃないんです
イエス様は神を信じたか何か別として
だけでもイエス様は一般的に人間に道徳的な教えを語ってるんだから
まあ一般的 裁くなかれよと
落ち着けと 裁いたら自分の気持ちが悪んじゃないか
大層悪い人間と思ったら自分の気持ちが悪いでしょうに
そこら辺で心の安らぎを語っている可能性あります
もう一つは 我々はその
その 価値判断っていうのは完全に潜在意識の力でしてありますが
無意識のうちにその潜在意識のパターンに従った価値判断
思考といいますかね それをこなしているんですよね
ということは あの もう完全に条件付けられた中で
あの やってますから まあ人は多少違うんですけども
全体として自分のパターンが自分の生き様っていうか
何かを決定してるんですよね
そして今 その すばっていうような言い方
生き方をやめるってことは
我々のその完全にパターン化してる
その動き 心の動きといいますか
というものを あの やめていくというか
全分解する  ですね  だから悟りと言うんですね
出世間と言うんですよ
生命とは全く違うと ということで
あの 理解しようとするなかれと
やってみなさいと 理解しようとしたら無理ってことは今はいくらかわかると思いますよ
では すばということにまた戻ります
すばとブッダが教える無常が反対やと
で それでシャボン玉の例を出したんですね
シャボン玉っていうのは我々
私にしても綺麗ですよ
皆様にしても綺麗だと思いますね
そこで普通綺麗な花やら綺麗な動物や何か見たら我々は大事にする
もう綺麗だから価値があるんですよ
人間の世界では それでシャボン玉も綺麗なのに誰も大事にしないのは何なのかと
何でしょうかね  すぐ割れてしまうもんだと知ってるから
でしょ だからすぐ割れてしまう
無常やってこと知ってるんだから
もう大事にしないわ 執着もしない
しかし楽しいの 別にどうったことはない
シャボン玉を作って あーよかった
綺麗でした それで終わった
まあ別 あっち向いて まあ別なことやっちゃう
それには だから すばで見る人々は無常は見てないんですよ
無常ではありませんという仮定で
前提ですばで見るんです
しかし 私たちのもうちっぽけな頭で考えても
ものは無常でしょ ということは
我々は本来すばで見ているんですよ
だからあまりにもバカ者ということなの
普通 普通のちっぽけな頭で考えたら無常であること知ってるのに
しかし すばで見ているんです
でも今日 頭で無常はわかるんですけど
無常がわからない  でしょ
だから頭でわかることをわかっているのに
生きている場合は無常でありませんという態度で生きているんですね
お釈迦様は無知というのは
その 無知というんですね
我々どんな生命にも本来ついてるものに無知というんです
すばで見ること では あまりもおどかしてはいけませんだから
そこら辺の話を柔らかくしますけど
そこまではわかると思います
すごい単純な例出しますから
皆様物事をできるだけ単純な例で考えることにして下さい
すると明確にわかるんですよ
じゃあ昨日も言ったんですけど
小学生ぐらいの知識能力は忘れてはいけませんと
それが修行する道だよと
すぐ嘘バレちゃいますよ
小学生ぐらいの能力あれば
我々は勉強しすぎてもうぐちゃぐちゃいろんなことを考えるんだから
何もわからなくなっちゃうんですね
だから勉強するのは悪くない
いくら勉強したっても
論理構成はあれぐらい単純にしておいた方が
もう見事に勉強もできるし
把握もできる じゃあ だからそういう例えなんか出したりする
シャボン玉は無常だから
知ってるんだから 誰一人も
それにはすばアプローチはしない
すばアプローチしないんだからって
シャボン玉は汚く見えるわけじゃないんです
その人 まあ綺麗ですよ
だから何よという状態なんです
シャボン玉どうです？綺麗
まあ綺麗は綺麗で だから何ですかと
もし別なものだったら
この絵はどうですか なんて綺麗ですかね
これ自分の部屋で飾っておきたいなとかね
それは無常ではないと状態なんですよ
ということになっちゃうんですね
だから無常で見る人は
だから何って 綺麗ですよ
だから何ですかという状態っていう
これ言葉のことで そんなに
まあなんか嫌な言葉に聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
囚われてはないんです
楽ですよ 悲しみも出てこない
シャボン玉が弾けたてて泣いた人は一人もいない
子供さえも泣きませんだから
だから憂い悲しみが消える
つまらない世界になるわけじゃないんです
憂い悲しみ欲が消えるだけっていうね
そこでスバーヌパッセンウィヘランタン
インドリエースアサンブタン
インドリヤというのは眼耳鼻舌身のこと
目耳鼻口体 まあそこからもう説明しなくてもわかるでしょ
目で見る時はアサンブタ自分をコントロールしてないんですね
ただバカみたいに見る
バカみたいに聞く そのまんまで聞いたり見たりする
スバで スバというアプローチで
ということはもう当たり前のことそれからは
すごいわかりやすいんですよ
スバという言葉をもう解けてしまえば
もうインドリエースアサンブタンというのはもう当たり前ではないかと
何か食べる ああ 美味しい美味しいとか食べちゃうし
それはもうコントロールしていないんですね
口を 綺麗なものを見ると
ああまあ綺麗綺麗と見るだけでね
だからスバーヌパッセン人が当然インドリエースアサンブタン
眼耳鼻舌身に対しては気をつけない
そこで我々は絶対スバでないアスバの見方わからない
わからないんだけど やりたいならば
インドリエースアサンブタンのところから始まるんです
眼耳鼻舌身を管理する
やたらに見ようとはしない
必要なものだけ見るとかね
心汚れるものは見ないようにするとかね
心汚れるものは聞かないようにするとか
もうコントロールする
そうすると じわじわとスバの見方が現れる可能性もあります
次にあることはもう当たり前
明確ですね ボージャナミチャアマッタンニョン
それだけじゃなくて 食べ物にもむちゃむさぼって食べる
マッタンニョンっていうのは量を知る
アマッタンニョンっていうのは量は知らない
食べ物の適度知らない人
それもスバの人にある問題ですよ
美味しいんだから食べる
体にいいんだから食べるという見方でしょ？みんな
体にいいんだから食べるんだったら
いくら食べてもいいんですよ
体にいいんだから 美味しいんだから食べるんだったら
だから美味しいから食べる
体にいいんだから食べる
体力をつけるために食べる
美しくなるために食べる
そういういろいろ目的で食べる人々はスバで食べてるんですね
必ずしも忘れるのは適量っていうことなんです
それで仏教ははっきりしているんです
出家にはね 体にいいんだから絶対食べてはいけない
美味しいっていうことで食べてはいけません
これで体力つくそうと食べてはいけません
食べる目的は何か 食べなきゃ壊れちゃいますよと
これが このシステムがね
ボロボロ壊れてしまう
だから修理修復ですよ
食べ物っていうのは この壊れかけてる体の修理修復です
そうすると適量っていうのは必ずあるでしょ
窓ガラス一つ割れたら何枚買いますか？窓ガラス 1枚でしょうに
なんで 100枚買うんですかね
だから修理だからね だから食べ物のアプローチは？仏教のアプローチは修理
何復？修復 修復 美味しいとかなんとかとかね
それはもう我々慣れてるんだから
聞くだけでも食欲がなくなっちゃうんですよ
聞いただけでもね これはなんとかのシェフがなんとかで作った
こちらから材料を取り寄せて作った食べ物ですから
どうぞと言うでしょうね
本人の俗世間の気持ちはわかりますよ
一生懸命ありがたいものをなんか自分にも食べさせようと思った気持ちはわかるんだけど
あの説明した途端 もう食欲がないんですよ
だったら結構ですとすぐ言いたくなる
私みたいな性格悪い人だったらすぐ言っちゃうんですよ
普通お坊さんは言いませんだけど
それでは結構ですと言えない場合は
もう受け取って誰かに必ずあげる
その人の同じ説明して
これは大変立派な 自分が食べない
なぜかというと 一応思考回路にインプットしちゃったんだから
その人はね 知ってることを忘れることできるでしょうに
だからこれがちゃんと仏説にのっとって食べようと思ったっても
余計な苦労しなくちゃいけないし
だからかえって苦しいというかね
楽なのは誰かにあげちゃうということで
誰かにあげちゃう それで傍受の道余ったんだ
だから すべて生きてる人々が
どうしても美しくなるために
体力作るために 長生きするために
健康になるために 体にいいんだからといういろんな目的で食べてるんだから
量がないんですよ 適度っていうのは成り立ちません
例えば我々の場合は 窓ガラス 1枚割ったら 1枚買おう
修理修復だから で あなたはいくらお金儲ければよろしいかと聞いちゃうと
私たちはその場合はお金さえあれば何でもできそうという考え方が出るんですね
そこで自分が何をやりたい生き物かというと
自分でわからないでしょうに
何をやりたく やりたがって
死ぬまで何をやりたがってる生き物か
自分でわからないんだから
お金になってくると いくらあっても別に断りませんという気持ちになるんですね
お金だったら なぜならば
お金っていうのはどんな幸福
幸福 幸福も どんなもう喜びも与えてくれる品物だと思ってるんだから
そちらには量が死んでいるんですね
だから 俗世間の考え方で言えばそれでしょ
それに当てはめて考えてください
それで すべて世の中を見ている人が
やっぱり食べる時ももう適
適度は知らずということは当たり前に決まってるんです
それからクシータンヒーナビーナ
怠けで頑張りはしない
その生き方自体怠けだからね
例えばあの決まってるパターンで
生命にすべて世の中を見るのはもう決まってるパターンで
それ別な見方もあるぞとはしない
そんなのは普通ではないか
常識ではないか 誰でもやってることではないかと
ということで すべて生きてみちゃう
それだけでもクシータ
怠けですよ ヒーナビーナ
努力はない それですばを破ろうとすると
これ並大抵なことじゃないんですよ
だから努力も必要なんですね
そういう人はタンウェパサハティマーロ
マーラっていうのは輪廻のこと
苦しみのことですよ マーラが来て
それは人格化した方があのすごい喋りやすいんだからね
マーラが来て もう思い存分やりたい放題やっちゃうんだと
どのようにかというと
ワートールカンはドゥッバラン
すごく弱々しい木が風が吹くと風のまんまでガチャガチャガチャガチャ動かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
自分で立っていられませんから
弱いんだから 風ののまんまで弱い木がもう動いたり折れたりいろいろします
そのように我々はこの存在のまんまで生きているんであって
もう苦しみのまんまで輪廻にやられて負けているんだと
逆の偈でアスバーナパッシーヴィヘランタン
あすばで見てみるんだよと
インドリエススサンブタン
だから五感をしっかりとコントロールしている
あすばで見る人は自動的に五感をコントロールする
ボージャナミチャマッタンニョ
食べるものについてはちゃんと適度知っているんです
自動的に 修復だから 修理修復のために食べているんだから
適量適量はちゃんと知っていると
ニッチャンアーラッダヴィーリヤ
常に精進 精進努力している
これ常でなきゃダメですよ
一時間だけあすばで見て
二十三時間あすばで見たって何の意味もないんです
あすばで見る自体がとんでもないことだから
やっぱりずっとあすばで見るような努力しないと
だからニッチャンアーラッダヴィーリヤ
タンウェーナッパサティーマーロー
マーラには何もできませんよと
いじめることはできません
どのように？ワートーセーランワパッバタン
石でできている山がある
風が吹いたってねじれる
びくともしないんだからね
その心を作りましょうということなんです